the Joe Rogan experience recently
running an ad have you been molested by
a Boy Scout or a [ __ ] priest call
this number it's never too late
blah blah blah blah blah blah you know
now you got they paid out three billion
mm-hmm five hundred plus just in Los
Angeles oh my god
ten years ago right that was ten years
ago so they might it's just crazy that
no one ever says hey maybe this isn't
really what God wants maybe you know I'm
saying I mean the people that are in the
church the people that are believers the
people that love to dress up nice and go
and behave kind and and and see all the
people in the community at the church
there's a good feeling that people get
from going to church but the fact that
it's connected to that is it's it's so
insane that it's still there it's so
insane that it hasn't been routed out
that this is still a giant problem and
relatively few people are going to jail
like relatively few like you know who
they wanted but they wanted that a
Ratzinger that Pope Ratzinger that's one
of the reasons why he had to step down
and one of the reasons why he stays in
the Vatican I was reading some article
about them bringing up charges crimes
against humanity against him that other
countries wanted to do that because this
guy used to ship kids or he used to ship
priests to places where they wouldn't
get in trouble like yeah this one guy
was accused of molesting boys and so he
shipped him to this place where he
worked with dead deaf kids and he
molested over a hundred deaf kids it's
like what did you do like you shipped a
child molester to a bunch of people that
wouldn't be able to talk about it well
like you'd be able to get away with it
easier there if they settle the case
that means it doesn't get prosecuted
right so that's why they won't go to
jail is that why they haven't gone to
jail see I don't understand it I don't
know these reports on why aren't they
going to jail and I like if you settle a
case you don't you don't call it like
they don't keep prosecuting I just I
guess if you make us like the person
decides to drop charges there was a guy
Boston
[ __ ] give a hundred thousand that we
will put him under the jail there was
some time boss and I read about years
ago them under the jail now I keep it
simple I'm still a Catholic I just don't
go to church I don't want to deal with
none of those people I don't want to
deal with nothing yeah and any religious
level I don't want to deal with him the
problem is whenever people get into a
position where everybody for the most
part is like humble around them and
scared of them and they have power like
I remember when my grandmother died we
went to a funeral and the guy couldn't
remember her name my grandmother's name
was Josephine he kept calling her
Geraldine and the priest who was
delivering the service we had to
interrupt him say it's Josephine and he
was like annoyed that they interrupt it
was like yes Josephine like he he
changed the net like he didn't even know
her name and when he's there to deliver
this God's message for the last you know
last time the family's gonna view the
body he doesn't know our name and when
he was corrected he was angry at us like
he had these Gin Blossoms all over his
face he's just some weird old guy who
got tricked and did this very strange
life and now it's at its end and he's
been living with robes on supposedly
being celibate his whole [ __ ] life
while people kiss his ass and pretend to
be something special because he talks
about the word of God but you could just
see in that one moment where he wasn't
even embarrassed that he said the wrong
name he was upset that people were
correcting him because you don't correct
priests so he's used to that it's all
there's no one checking him there's no
one checking them at all everyone who
goes there is in this state of worship
and they're the ones who deliver the
Word of God
dressed like wizards like they're the
only people in society that are allowed
to dress like wizards in modern American
society they dress like [ __ ] wizards
and we're like yeah that's how father
dresses father dresses like a wizard
like do you know people are gonna look
back at that and go why didn't they
think the outfits
weird why didn't they think it was silly
that this pedophile dresses up like a
wizard and you're not supposed to say
anything to him what is that like what
is what is with the outfits the fact
that all that shit's still around like
there's nowhere in the Bible that says
priests have to dress like that no way
there's no where the whole thing so
bizarre it's it's you're wearing stuff
that made you look like you were very
special to really poor people 500 years
ago that's what you're wearing you
wearing stuff that would impress people
that didn't know any better that
probably couldn't read and so before
Martin Luther translated these the the
scriptures so that people could read it
like a phonetic language before that
people have no idea what what the
priests were reading they just relied on
the priests they relied on the priests
to tell them what the Word of God was
but now something they could read it for
themselves and Martin Luther was saying
he should probably interpret it yourself
too and they were like oh my god
so I said where are they vo old enough
to go to church when it was still in
Latin oh they would say something used
to only be in Latin - like seventies or
sixties really yeah I remember they
would say some things in Latin because I
remember I'd be five years old going
what in the [ __ ] are these people's what
type of kid were you between the age of
five and ten were you aggressive were
you quiet we did much more introverted
okay from the ages of five and ten I
went to the white changed until I got
hit in there with a lunchbox but I
believed I really did believe Jo I
really do believe I believe in God I
believe that my father was in heaven I
believe that I thought of [ __ ] you know
then I got introduced to Catholic school
and that just [ __ ] me up completely
because I believed but I didn't believe
on the tail end of it it was supposed to
be loving Liza's nan smacking me why is
this nun hitting me with a [ __ ] rule
of thumbs I am and then I saw the anger
in their heart and it turned me off
completely like I didn't lie
today I'm still a Catholic in some
boards yeah when my body goes I'd like
to go to a [ __ ] church you know right
but I don't hold it
I remember selling cars and Boulder my
guy came in and we started talking and
he was 50 wasn't a good-looking guy look
like that [ __ ] guy am I just a year
old chick with him and obviously have to
take him on a demo right I figured out
that he could [ __ ] her and [ __ ]
no I realized that he was [ __ ] her
she was like his receptionist or
something okay
but after when we got back I also
realized he was my father lost friend
Wow
so I asked my father more bother me he's
and he's on the board of the church what
he's a great man you know and I still
remember him
this was Sacred Heart Church in Boulder
Colorado in fact that's it same church
the head of the football team went to
bill McCarthy and all that should I'd
see his [ __ ] family there and and
then all sit in the front this [ __ ]
scumbag would sit in the second pew with
his fat [ __ ] ugly wife you know she
had ugliest [ __ ] wife in the [ __ ]
Church they would hit her with the net
with that money that they would just hit
her with it
like [ __ ] you just ugly but the point
was that I never respected it that
you're cheating on your wife but living
in here right there playing the [ __ ]
I'm a good guy
[Applause]